yeah welcome to this video playing mmm I
cannot aam I captain whatever i am from
the u.s. son named in that Luca sheet I
shiet a whatever difficult name all
right so we have a center game with the
default this is an aggressive opening
for white this is the main recipe
against this I know it looks a bit bit
bit strange but but it's actually strong
black is winning the central pawn this
is normal but white White's compensation
is it's not really sufficient but it
leads to notoriously murky plane look at
this position Anita died needed to put
the rock on g4 okay um let's see the
Queen of3 yeah I don't really want to
give up a PCM so on go to be six maybe
even nullity just briefly thought 95 but
this cannot really work with the no
development at all okay I'm so what now
the look is attacked to deform I could
also consider 94 of course attacking the
Queen again it would probably need to go
to d3 Knight e5 is going to play Queen e
2 and then morooka sucess looking a
funnier than ever okay hard the same I
could also go to deform 92 and then it
moves like 85 switching to attacking
mode
also work g6 but but I'll Bishop d3 is
not really a mix now 95 okay maybe just
go here this is the problem of this of
this opening it is it is not good for
white but it's completely crazy and you
need some time often to to figure out
what so what's really going on okay what
I'm trying to do is play Queen e7
attacking attacking a three and not
quite sure what he does to defend that
you can play king be too but all the Sun
I don't know it's not particularly
convincing maybe complain like night a
form yeah at this one i don't really i
didn't really fear but ok let's seem
just capture probably come on Chad
capture this and then d 50 Bishop c5
first oh wait I can I can play that
actually attacking h1 and sort of
forcing the Queen trade oh I forgot
about that one mmm i got about this move
on now we can you know he tell us that
and this was not planned okay after the
trade Bishop takes when the rukon G
successor is almost wrapped so he
managed to really irritate me it with
this play I came I need to need to get
get those pieces involved I'm not quite
sure about this position maybe it's not
not so
and even but it's obviously very very
strange okay yeah i was going for a five
yeah maybe I just need to go I could
have sacrificed on g4 but I'm not not
convinced I'm trying f5 of g5 it's not
playing that it's all very strange I
don't understand anything here and
thought the other line was pretty good
for white not that this is bad for what
I don't I don't understand anything but
the other solution look pretty good okay
just threw him yeah it's still very
murky but objectively speaking black
should be fine
mostly is playing quickly trying to
trying to oops oops this was my lip I
wanted to go to c4 okay let's hope that
nothing bad has happened I just wanted
to relocate to see form and not here hmm
yeah maybe queen age 21 I was right okay
but now I can I think I can get the
bishop to e5 which really should secure
my position the king is is quite safe
than check yeah I can do that I can
always go to e7 oh yeah i don't i don't
mind that really if it takes check I'm
completely safe now on your 7 and I get
an attack myself fruk a five that's the
way to go oh yeah okay
he's just plain crazy move over move
hoping to win on time just a very bad
play sorry um I can give one check
exactly and then when it's all done
check white resigned that that's it
while Queen v8 was really a funny moment
I didn't what to play this move at all
but it it seemed to be okay yeah it's
basically this is opening it just leads
to completely crazy positions but
objectively speaking it's just not
particularly good for wide maybe a
specialist will say otherwise and
present some tricky lines but in general
this is very fishy before this is
probably completely unplayable mean and
it looks it looks just just awful but of
course it's tricky the rukon 36 and I
think at one point he probably had a
good position this is pretty clear check
and night before now while the apt
Queenie for was a complete level now and
94s the is the right move yes of course
intending to use the loop here and of
course I'm just intending night eggs and
this is actually pretty difficult to to
prevent yeah this is completely lost
toward completely compass on- form yeah
this was the way to go and after this
silly mover is really getting lots of
play yeah
you won yeah I'm not sure now then ya
hear ya typical the computer moves are
very difficult to have ya to find for
human 98 intending would be 60 this is
probably rather good but I didn't
consider this and he should just play a
five of course I didn't understand
neither five at all f5 I need to go here
and then ok you can take the exchange of
you once and also just try to continue
from here this is just a very funny
piece I'm not quite sure how to continue
and there are many ideas maybe 92 even
intending oops maybe intending at one
point to play Knight c3 but you can also
just take I mean then at least you're
not the material down anymore and let's
say H more this is just good for white
mean it's probably not not a win or
anything computers about 11 to white
yeah it's look look it looks bad I
already had spoiled it with Queenie for
really the 95 is just not making any
sense TM like as black is basically
winning I only made it tricky with Queen
B 8 but it doesn't seem to spoil
anything after that I think it's it's
very easy because you get the bishop on
your file and you're completely safe
behind the same central ball here it's
just a deadly attack Queen a 5 and so on
I could have taken also our queen c5 is
also the move I forgot about that yeah
Quincy three Queen a one mate this is
very difficult to carry on c4 I have
queen d phone
yap could have played better numerous
times yeah an interesting interesting
very messy game thanks for watching